We just discussed some behavioral aspects of treatment such as token economies
and systematic desensitization, but let's touch on cognitive therapy and then
see how the 2 are combined. Cognitive therapies any type of cycle therapy that
works to restructure Irrational thought patterns. Here, the therapist will talk
to the client in an attempt to identify irrational thought patterns, and then
the therapist will actually challenge the client on those thoughts. For
example, perhaps the client tells the therapist, I'm fat, ugly, smelly, stupid,
and nobody loves me. The therapist would challenge her on those irrational
thoughts. She may, for example, ask the client Is it really the case that
nobody loves you? You have the support of your family, your friends, and your
boyfriend. And they've all contributed in some way to help you through this
depression that you're experiencing. And that's challenging the clients
thoughts. Now challenging a person to look at their irrational thoughts in a
logical way, can perhaps change a persons thought patterns.